on this episode of Imagine a world I
guess the hope is that
aesthetically about
everything about
about recognizing that you know everyone
needs to be a part of this and we don't
want just the people that are hyper Tech
focused and working on technology
involved it's very much like voting you
think that you're one person your vote
doesn't matter but in actuality it's
like no if you and everyone else thinks
like that then it does affect things so
it's very much getting everyone involved
and making sure that everyone is
thinking about this
welcome to
come choose from the future
this podcast is based on a contest we
ran to gather ideas from around the
world about what a more positive future
might look like in 2045
we hope the diverse ideas you're about
to hear will spark discussions and maybe
even collaborations but you should know
that the ideas in this podcast are not
to be taken as F alignedors positions
and now over to our host Guillaume
reason
[Music]
welcome to the imagine a world podcast
by the future of Life Institute I'm your
host Guillaume reason
in this episode we'll be exploring a
world called Crossing points which was a
third place winner of flies World
building contest
this team put a lot of thought into how
new technologies might work alongside
human nature rather than trying to
change us directly
the most advanced AI systems in this
world are extremely large and expensive
to run so are mostly limited to
political and corporate use
Crossing points has a special focus on
exploring how simpler tools are
experienced by a range of diverse
individuals
there's an emphasis on the unanticipated
impacts of new technologies on those who
weren't considered during their
development
from Urban families in Indonesia to
anti-technology extremists in America
where shown that there's something to
learn from every human story
this world emphasizes the importance of
broadening our lens and empowering
marginalized voices in order to build a
future that will be bright for more than
just a privileged view
this world was created by a diverse team
of five living in the UK
our guests today are Elaine check and
Vanessa honchka both PhD candidates at
the University of Bristol
Elaine has a background in art and
design and is studying the accessibility
of Technologies for older adults
Nessa is studying responsible AI
practices of technologists using methods
like storytelling to promote diverse
voices and AI research
their third teammate Tashi namgyao is
also a University of Bristol PhD
candidate who's studying the
controllability of deep generative
models
the remaining team members are Dr Susan
leckeltz who researches the applications
and implications of emerging
Technologies at the University of
Edinburgh and Nicole augston a British
civil servant delivering welfare policy
to UK citizens
we'll have an SN Elaine thanks for
joining us hello hi thank you for having
us thanks for being here
um so I'm curious first of all how the
five of you on your team came to work
together on this project
so
um I think Tashi was the one who first
spotted
um the competition for the future of
Life Institute and Tashi Elaine and I we
all do our research in the same lab
um so the Bristol interaction group so
that yeah that's how we know each other
and then we were like thinking about who
else to pull in and
um Susan and Nicole they both did their
undergrad at Edinburgh with me so I knew
them and I knew they'd be sort of
interested and Nichols like more of the
policy person so we needed him so all of
all the rest of us were kind of in the
human computer interaction space
um and yeah nickel we pulled in
for some politics knowledge can you say
a little bit more about your particular
skill sets
I I guess thinking about me and Susan
were both more in the sort of creative
side of things so my background is an
art and design and I know that Susan has
been doing a lot of
um creative informatics
Tashi also is kind of in the creative
sphere I think he's our sort of
musician in Residence I guess cool
artist yeah yeah he does music and AI
stuff yeah so he's doing like music from
people's Doodles which is very cool yeah
yeah that was his like last project but
also like in the AI space
and I do kind of research and
responsible AI so thinking about making
it more ethical and thinking about how
to take all the kind of responsibly eye
work that's based on guidelines and very
abstract just now and taking it into the
more concrete so
um yeah that's how I fit in
how would you say that your personal
perspectives like like where you live or
your your educational backgrounds have
influenced how you think about the
future
so that that's really I think part of
why we came together to do this is
because we all were coming from sort of
diverse backgrounds so I if you can't
tell from my accent are am American
um so I grew up in the U.S but then I
did my masters in Japan
um I know Vanessa is a very
Multicultural
she's from I'm gonna let you talk about
yourself
right here well yeah I'm I was born in
Germany I'm a calf German half
Indonesian that's why I like brought in
that Indonesian yeah it makes sense but
I've like lived in several places like
like Elaine now I'm studying in the UK
and yeah I've lived in Cameroon I've
worked in Italy so it was quite
important for me to kind of see the like
little stories that actually happen all
around the world and kind of think of
things in a more decentralized way as
opposed to like Humanity always going
into One Direction but actually there's
many things going around that don't
feature so often like the big media
landscape yeah
thank you
the world of Crossing points looks
pretty different from our own with agis
debating philosophy on TV and hybrid 3D
printed meets in grocery stores
but the people in this world are still
basically the same
there is still a dazzling array of
languages and cultures which shape our
attitudes toward Technologies our hopes
and dreams haven't fundamentally changed
and neither have our blind spots and
shortcomings
I wanted to hear more about how the
people of Crossing points navigate their
new world and how AI tools manage to
help so many of them flourish
how do people find fulfillment in your
world like what's a good life like
yeah I think there's kind of like two
aspects to that so there's one that we
kind of brought out which was like the
self-expression side so people like to
be creative and I guess it's something
that kind of exists now as well like
they try to improve themselves and
become better but then on the other hand
we also thought that like the social
side was very important so if technology
takes over a lot of the burden of work
then ideally we would also have more
time to engage with each other
um socially and help other people and
volunteer maybe yeah yeah one big factor
in your world you describe is the spread
of personalized AI tutors that kind of
helps people do this personal growth and
connection stuff the most popular one
you describe is skill jump and it's the
system that basically gets to know you
and then recommends new things you
should learn to try to reach your goals
I really like this one's origin story it
kind of started as a corporate employee
OE training system but then it gets
taken over by an activist Collective
when the company goes under and kind of
becomes like a tool for the people and
I'm curious to hear more about how
people in your world actually use this
um like you're saying things have really
changed you know you have Universal
basic income and many jobs cannot be
automated so what do people actually
aspire to what are they trying to to do
with their lives with these tools
yeah I think
they try to go
um and Beyond beyond what could actually
do before so one of the ideas was that
it was a bit like an immersive system
with VR and like the whole world is kind
of open to you kind of like you know the
internet but in a lot more immersive way
and it also would take away your
physical limitations that you might have
and so we were thinking of all kinds of
hobbies and creative stuff that people
would explore without the physical
limitation of where you can actually go
and what your body could actually do
Yeah you mentioned people like rock
climbing in VR with like muscle feedback
and stuff like that yeah so in your
world agis are fairly rare mostly
because they have this huge scale they
just it turns out they require a lot of
processing power in your world and so
there's a lot of associated costs
they're heavily regulated by a un
Consortium and so they're mostly used in
industrial and governmental contexts
like their AGI Oracles in the US and EU
that help to predict policy outcomes I'm
curious how people outside of these
contexts relate to those agis like what
do they know about them and what they're
capable of yeah I think what you
described there is actually like quite
an important part of how we view agis
like the fact that they're a resource
consuming things because I think that in
a lot of the like AI conversation right
now imagines AI just being everywhere
because it's something that lives in the
cloud and just like magically does
things for you but actually this
technology is like all rooted in a
material sense like it it lives in a
data center which like consumes a lot of
energy energy I don't know chat GPT
apparently took 100 million dollars to
just train and yeah chat GPT is nowhere
close to AGI yet
um so how how much would anything else
kind of like consume it's kind of like
the state or the economy and people like
know about these things and interact
with those agis and like a limited sense
in very defined settings but it's not
like they are always interacting like
they know them but they don't
necessarily have a specialist yeah yeah
yeah another theme I liked in your world
was how diets have shifted so you have
most meat products now being hybrids of
lab grown and plant-based materials they
use like AI assisted Gene editing to
develop new textures and flavors so
there's this stuff called chicken which
is this really popular combination of
chicken and bacon sounds great to me and
you cite an outbreak of bovine diseases
in the 2030s as kind of speeding along
this transition I'm curious how this
shift in diet has affected the way
people think about animals if it has I
mean I think something that is sort of a
theme throughout our world is that we
don't really see a whole lot changing in
human behavior because I think things
are very gradual and I think we kind of
even thought about this as the shift
towards animals thinking about like
whale meat that's consumed in Japan
um it's very common and normal in some
areas so especially amongst like the I
knew indigenous people of Japan eating
whale meat as cultural and very accepted
but you know the majority of the country
is like no let's not do that so I think
there is always sort of these shifts
that occur with our like attitudes
toward animals but like the people who
are die hard like the vegans who really
care about animals and animal cruelty
will always be there but I don't think
you're going to have like a mass change
of people's minds interesting
[Music]
Crossing points Embraces Humanity in all
this diversity and looks for the
solutions that human nature presents
alongside the problems
it shows that there's something to learn
from everyone's experience and that even
the most radical attitudes can offer
insights that help to Build a Better
World
I wanted to hear more about this
human-centered inclusive approach to
problem solving and how it allows the
people of Crossing points to create a
world where so many of them can flourish
I really appreciated how your world
focused so much on like kind of
unconsidered perspectives or under
considered perspectives people who we
don't often think about when we're
developing AI Technologies and systems
there's still this ongoing struggle for
accessibility and inclusion like in one
of your short stories there's this
Indonesian Grandpa who complains that
this super Advanced AI Healthcare tool
that he's using still doesn't understand
his dialect I'm curious to hear some of
the other approaches that are being
taken in your world to tackle these
issues
so my my research is working with
accessibility and accessibility of
technology and I work with particularly
older adults and older adults who have
dementia so I think I'm very hyper aware
of the the limitations that technology
even currently has in terms of
accessibility and inclusion so I think
knowing how the limitations are now you
know there's this constant sort of need
to create accessibility and
accessibility is still sort of
oftentimes a second thought or something
that has to be built after the product
is built I think it's hard to see that
going away
in the future which is really sad
because you know if you make something
accessible to one group it tends to make
it accessible to everyone so there's
really no reason to not have
accessibility designed and built into
these systems that we're creating but
we live in an ableist society and so
that really keeps this stuff from
happening and this sort of is why we
continue to have these failures of
accessibility and inclusion can you
imagine a future where you know as
you're saying that the rising tide lifts
all boats and this accessibility area
like what if AI systems were able to
give us that foresight and consideration
could could we imagine a world where
there aren't as many accessibility
issues or is this just something kind of
inherent to any technology that is a
tough one
um actually I think this one I'm gonna
kind of turn over to Vanessa because I
think Vanessa you you really work with
sort of getting companies who are
creating these AI systems to think about
inclusion and think about the ethics and
I think that's part of where we need to
go if we want this to happen so I mean
the the way that I see that AI is just
now is is that it's being trained on
usually historical data
and so kind of being trained on the
world as it is right now
um
so yeah I find a I struggle to imagine a
world where it could overcome most of
those challenges I mean it's it's the
way I also I guess I would see it in my
research where I'm like working with
developers who just reflect on their
technology and then sometimes I'll hear
them asks oh so are we are we there yet
are we like ethical now and I think it's
the same with like accessibility it's
like are we there yet are we in that
accessible World although it's like a
continuous process where we are
sometimes redefining also what we think
and learning so I can't imagine us yeah
arriving at that Big Goal we probably
have to continuously be open to engaging
and reflecting and and questioning and
what will the accessibility needs of the
people of the future be we we don't know
yeah
yeah I think you you brought up an
excellent point of like constantly
needing to be questioning and aware and
constantly changing our views I mean I
think in any science we're constantly
reevaluating and renegotiating what our
theories are what are our hypothesises
are that sort of thing and I know from
the accessibility standpoint we have
moved from sort of the medical model of
how we approach technology youth design
and how we approach even you know
Medical Care to more of like thinking
about in an independent approach to now
even thinking about sort of this
interdependent approach where it's
people are interconnected and there are
reliances that occur whether you're
able-bodied or not able-bodied yeah
interesting and I guess even when things
aren't designed with certain groups in
mind people sometimes just like
appropriate technology in different ways
and then just make them their own and
and manage and in in ways I can't even
imagine I don't know if you have a good
example of that Elena
you made me think of a great example so
there was recently someone did a
research project and um the paper was
called my Zelda cane and it was looking
at you know in video games there's not a
lot of accessibility games created or
games that have those sort of
accessibility elements but people would
hack the games so for instance the
Legend of Zelda they would use their
sword and they would hack at things to
kind of know where they were in space
so very much like how people with visual
impairments use canes they would use
their sword like a game fascinating so
yeah yeah great great research yeah yeah
so sometimes people will just make it
their own you won't even have to
have someone to imagine what what it
could be here yeah right although that's
not to say that accessibility should not
be designed foreign
so in your world there's this huge
impact on the labor market from Ai and
Robotics Technologies one of your other
short stories has this household robot
that can do all this different types of
Labor like cooking and cleaning even
harvesting these plants that are being
grown in the attic and it seems like the
people in this house really just need to
delegate there's not much else for them
to do physically in the house to take
care of things
um and the devaluation of manual labor
in general that results from this in
your world leads to the manual labor
Revolution I'm curious to hear a little
bit more about this Revolution and its
impacts on your world
so I want to shout out Susan because she
was she really
made a great point about this you know
technology has historically been partial
to automation so the creation of the
microwave the creation of the washing
machine sort of all of these home
appliances and this ohm Appliance boom
that occurred in the 20s the 20th
century led to the decrease in household
labor and so decrease from almost 60
hours a week in the 1900s to 18 hours a
week by 1975. so
that led to this change in the workforce
so this is one reason why we see more
women in the workforce is because they
don't need to be spending all their time
at home necessarily doing these domestic
tasks so I think being one of three
women on this team we do very much think
about this feminist perspective on
Automation and the impact on society but
that then also means that we have to
think about sort of the invisible labor
that occurs so oftentimes when we have
technologies that are created to promote
automation that creates sort of this
invisible labor which means that someone
has to maintain it someone has to be the
one you know doing the updates someone
has to be the one who you know make sure
that it's plugged in and it's charged
and again this this labor tends to fall
on women and carers I think the the idea
we had there kind of came from asking
the question where are we going with all
of this when we're like automating
different tasks that humans usually do
then we we kind of need to rethink about
what kind of tasks are left for the the
humans and and how should we reshape the
way that people then were yeah that that
reminded me yeah we did we did think
that like one of the the major sort of
results of having this manual labor
Revolution would be greater expansion of
Ubi and I think we tried to look into
well where are there already sort of
cases of Ubi working and sort of
thinking then if this becomes that some
people will not have jobs how do we
become a sustainable society and how do
we you know
sort of think about how we can take care
of each other yeah I really like how
your world kind of takes human nature
and tries to work with it so much you
know there's a really big dose of kind
of psychological inertia in there that I
think is is true for how you respond to
things and one example that is how your
approach reducing Global conflicts so
you have this AGI system that just
decides where to put stockpiles and
trade routes and it kind of puts them in
key locations to try to reduce
geopolitical tensions
um of course now controlling this AGI
that decides where stuff goes then
becomes a focus of conflict in itself
but the AGI sees is coming and it
creates this virtual War space where
countries can like compete for shares
they give control over how to update the
AGI and I thought this was a really
interesting Twist on like how to curtail
some of our worst instincts and kind of
shift the game through AI can you say a
little bit more about how this whole
system works
so so we have to give credit where
credit is due this is definitely Nichols
baby
um so our political person of course
um
so it definitely was kind of
I'm not exactly sure where nickel was
coming from but when I've read what he's
talked about with this sort of virtual
War space it kind of is we know that
humans come with an aggressive nature
it's our Evolution it's just kind of
it's gonna be there so having sort of
something that is going to give people
Stakes where there is higher Stakes is
some way that you can actually sort of
maybe mitigate that aggression because
like I was talking with Vanessa earlier
and we talked you know the Olympics was
supposed to be sort of that kind of
thing where it's this Global competition
not violent as a way of kind of being
like ooh who's the strongest country I
never thought about that can you say
anything about how like what what is the
virtual War activities involve is it
like a game of some kind or like so we
had nickel give us like
um a rundown of what he was thinking and
it sounded very much to me like betting
on sports so if Russia and China were in
a war and it was okay everyone in this
virtual space has a share they can put
it towards either China or Russia
whoever they back and then that can give
them sort of virtual assets that they
can use to combat each other in this
world a little bit like a big game of
Risk is that sort of in the right
ballpark you think Mika loves risk maybe
that's why oh there you go
but but I I think you're right I think
you're right I I I'm sure he was
thinking about risk and like other ways
that we can kind of mitigate against you
know our violent nature yeah I'm curious
kind of from this more philosophical
level you know some of our other winning
worlds have technologies that let people
change themselves directly like become
different types of people have different
desires even than they had before what
are your thoughts on like what parts of
human nature can or should be changed
and which ones we should try to work
around in this way
yeah I think I think Elaine you said it
before like I don't think we really saw
humans
changing so much as one we have a very
diverse World there where there is no
like one human nature and like not one
kind of human that will be in the future
I think if anything we wanted to
preserve human nature maybe yeah to me
that almost seems dystopian where it's
like if I was to change my will if I was
to be like well I don't want to be so
altruistic I want to be able to make a
lot of money and just turn off that that
part of my brain that is like don't use
people
it feels like it would be a bit I don't
know inhumane no I really appreciated
this this angle that your team took on
of like let's change the things around
us and and see if we can make things
better in that way rather than trying to
change ourselves as an interesting
approach
I feel like this also gets into some
conversations about ableism as you were
saying earlier this idea of like we
should change the affordances of our
environment and the way that our society
is built to make people's lives easier
the way they are instead of trying to
like quote fix people yeah for sure
well even though Technologies in your
world don't try to like change human
nature so much in this way not everyone
is on board with these Technologies so
one particular group that you highlight
calls themselves human that's hu men for
heavily unplugged men and they're kind
of an extremist sometimes terroristic
anti-technology group they they overlap
with Q Anon and anti-effects folks that
we have today and their most extreme
members live off grid in like these tiny
homes and or as I said sometimes do like
terroristic acts I'm just curious what
the AGI systems in your world think of
these folks like is it a priority to try
to de-radicalize them or bring them into
the fold
so I am crediting Susan for this because
Susan is a big fan of this book radicals
by Jamie Bartlett and in the in that
book he you know discusses that there
are different radical groups that have
existed all across time and space and
radicals can go from you know sort of
evangelicals to sort of transhumanists
so these these groups exist and have
exist and oftentimes they exist because
they're demonstrating a symptom of where
the status quo is failing and it's not
working for everyone so even though they
can offer visions of the future they are
often flawed and dystopian but they
still are sort of telling us about what
is going on and what we need to be
critical of so kind of getting people to
think more critically I mean
obviously you know I think there's
there's something where we can compare
it to today where we do have like the
anti-vaxxer folks and so thinking about
well why do they not feel that vaccines
are you know safe what what where are we
failing in society that these people
don't feel like this is something that's
for them yeah kind of taking it as
feedback rather than a challenge to to
neutralize it yeah yeah so it ties back
to us being like well we don't want to
take away free will so you know that's
sort of a trade-off of giving people
free will is that you will have these
radical groups emerge interesting
this team has deep expertise in
understanding human interactions with
technology and they've clearly spent a
lot of time thinking about how new tools
might impact individuals as well as
Society at large I was curious to hear
their thoughts on current discussions
around issues like inclusive AI
development data privacy and the
potential for AI tools to replace human
creative labor
a major theme in your world is this
focus on the unpredictable kind of
trickle-down impacts of AI systems
across society and you show how AI tools
don't need to be incredibly powerful or
develop their own agency or anything in
order to be really transformative you
have these really pretty simple
innovations that have unexpected impacts
on different people
um this is especially true for minority
groups that aren't being considered
during development so what are your
thoughts on the current discussions
around diversity and accessibility in AI
I'm sure you have many of them I'd love
to hear yeah
yeah so many yeah I think tasks you
mentioned this in conversation that
currently like in AI diversity often
means how can we get different people to
be more like us rather than like how can
we learn from others to be more like
them so there is a lot of diversity
going on for the sake of selling more
products or just having yeah more people
in a diverse Tech Team but when they're
in that diverse Tech Team they're not
necessarily able to bring their whole
diversity self they are just having to
like assimilate to
um to like what the tech world is like
and I guess I kinda well it kind of
comes back to what we were saying before
that inclusivity is really hard
accessibility is hard like and we
just like sticking a rainbow flag on
something is not really
yeah it's not really what we need to do
we need to like constantly question
ourselves and realize that yeah that
sometimes there are groups which have
opposing views and then trying to like
manage that conflict is also quite
difficult so I think it's also something
that is becoming more of a discussion I
think particularly since the black lives
matter movement is thinking about equity
and not equality so really trying to
move towards what is equity and
understanding how to actually create
that I was recently reading an article
about there was sort of this
organization or non-profit organization
that was created by a black woman and a
white woman and the black woman
eventually was like I can't be a part of
this organization you're not treating me
equitably and it kind of became in the
articles that I was reading up very much
she said she said kind of thing and to
identify myself I am a white woman from
the US and so I in reading that article
was like huh well what how would I react
what what is the the issue here and I
think what I recognize is that you know
when there's someone who's traditionally
not in a position of power and they ask
for something to be heard
um it needs to be honored sort of the
first time they're asked because if I'm
asking for Equitable pay or I'm saying
that like this maybe isn't great even if
I'm asking in a nice way and it seems
like I'm asking for a discussion that's
kind of been allowing and perpetuating
these microaggressions that people are
constantly facing so I think it is sort
of
when we're thinking about creating these
tools and developing to ensure that
there's more outcomes for more diverse
users thinking about how we can listen
and create Equity so you're kind of
saying like the the barriers to being
heard and to expressing yourself in a
safe way for some people are just much
higher and so we should be kind of
turning up the gain on that feedback
from them
yeah yeah for sure thinking about people
who are or who have been historically in
power or given positions of power being
more hyper aware of the work that they
need to be doing how would you challenge
people who are developing AI tools to
think differently about about that work
to ensure better outcomes for all their
users there's several aspects to this so
there's firstly create a team a
developer team that's diverse and
doesn't only represent one type of
person then the second part is but also
leveraging that and letting developers
bring in those diverse views and then I
mean obviously you can't always have a
developer team that represents every
single section of society but you can
also like like in our our research there
are other ways of engaging with
communities like participatory design
um like just engage with the end users
and issues they might see with whatever
you're you're designing yeah yeah well I
think that's a kind of a limitation that
we faced being from Academia so I think
like both me and Vanessa are PhD
students so there's a lot of time and
sort of energy that can be put into
looking at users and doing user research
that I think
because we
oftentimes are
sort of creating these Technologies from
a consumer standpoint from a capitalist
standpoint there is less time that's
given to user needs and understanding
people
so in some ways we need to change that
sort of culture that occurs in Tech
Industries but
yeah it's tough
so if I can try to summarize I guess I'm
hearing to listen more and to be
prepared to truly be challenged and and
take these perspectives into account in
their development work yeah
um
did I listen good yeah great
um awesome oh yeah one one other thing I
would say is understanding the context
that you're building something in and
questioning sometimes if AI is the right
tool so I think sometimes it's kind of
like that hammer and a nail story you
know like when you've got Hammer
everything looks like a nail and
sometimes that's what AI feels right now
like we've got Ai and there's a problem
how can we fix this problem with AI
instead of understanding where the
problem comes from because the AI might
just be like a Band-Aid for like a
bigger structural
issue that kind of Lies underneath it or
sometimes there might be like an easier
fix that doesn't require AI so I think
treating AI more preciously sometimes
um instead of just thinking
um every problem needs AI as a fix
oh man I want to be a total Millennial
and be like ah snaps for Vanessa this is
great
um because it is very much like I think
even just technology in general people
are like ooh technology will fix
everything technology is the answer and
then like
I do a lot of community-based research
so community-based participatory design
and so I'm working with people and
oftentimes technology is not what they
need they need policy changes they need
they need better transportation they
need like resources that governments
need to be able to give them but you
know
technology
that brings me around to the human group
in your world and again I really
appreciate how you're really the kind of
living what you're saying in your world
about taking these Fringe groups as
feedback you know this group is Extreme
and sometimes they're terroristic and
that is obviously a huge problem but
nonetheless their concerns are showing
us something real about the world and
one of those concerns that people really
take seriously is this conversation that
develops around data ownership and
consent because a lot of the basic
necessities in your world like just like
accessing goods and using a passport are
monitored by AI systems so this can make
it really hard for people to operate
with their privacy intact we also talk
about the other side of the coin where
people who don't have data in the system
who are attempting to like immigrate for
example are discriminated against for
being Daedalus because nothing is known
about them so I'm curious to hear more
of your thoughts about current
narratives around data privacy uh I I
have feelings about data privacy
um
I mean I think part of it is is I am
extremely guilty of everything that is
bad where being like aren't we oh yeah
whatever my data no one's spying on me
who cares I don't I don't have anything
important but I think it it always at
least for me comes back to my data is
not concrete I can't see it so it means
I don't know yeah it's hard to know
what's at stake until you have a problem
until someone steals your data so that's
my data
yeah yeah and I think it was like my my
mom had her identity stolen I'm sorry
and well I mean I think it's actually
pretty common and it's but it's awful
and it's like you don't realize how much
is at stake when you have your data
stolen and how how much of your privacy
is taken away until that sort of
negative thing happens and I don't think
in today's world we really do a great
job of explaining data privacy and
what's being done with our data
interesting yeah and I think it's quite
tiring for an end user to try to
understand what is going on I mean we're
in the school of computer science but we
don't know everything I can't imagine
how complicated it must be for a lay
user and that's kind of like the
conflict that's in the human like on the
one hand you need the services to do
things
but on the other hand you don't have the
time to engage with all the Privacy fine
print to understand if this is really
what you want to give your data up for
these things so there's yeah a lot of
questions around like the accessibility
of the language and yeah I don't I don't
think we've got all the answers yet yeah
not not personally or in the computer
science world yeah well on the sort of
positive end of it in your world there
is this trust index that a lot of
democracies start using which I think is
Loosely based on China's social credit
system and is portrayed as this
generally good thing that decreases
isolation increases trust I'm curious
how that relates to this broader
discussion about data privacy it's just
just like the good end of the spectrum
yeah I mean I think it it's sort of one
of those things that brings up allowing
the question of who owns data and sort
of who you trust with your data and I
think that's something that is still
really under explored I think this is
something that as being a researcher
I've become more aware of and I think
well being a researcher and being
originally from the US is being aware of
where server Farms are and how that
actually means someone else controls
your data so like oftentimes I think
especially through universities we're
very strict about where you can store
certain files or certain information and
I think especially in the UK things need
to be on servers that are in Europe or
in the UK they can't be on servers in
the US because the U.S government can
potentially tap into those servers and
see that data and I think that's
something that like I wouldn't have
known until I got into this because I
would have thought oh yeah if I use this
website and you know the company's based
in the US it doesn't matter my data
saved in the cloud it's saved wherever
um and I think that there's definitely
this disconnect that is happening and
potentially needs to be remedied in some
way it sounds like in general you're
calling for more kind of transparency
and like concreteness of these
discussions like what is the data where
is the data and like what's at stake if
it's taken it does seem very kind of
abstract to me as well when I think
about these issues yeah I think that's
definitely my point of view I don't want
to speak necessarily for everyone else
on the team
another theme you explored that I really
appreciated was ai's relationship with
the Arts you have a really nuanced
portrayal of this so things don't go
well at first the creative sector gets
devalued and AI starts being criticized
for kind of just making cookie cutter
predictive media that people will like
but eventually AI systems get better and
they start to make genuine contributions
to culture like new types of creative
work and human creative work also starts
regaining value because handmade items
start coming back into Vogue so there's
the strong demand for what you call slow
creative labor
and if it's always headed tracking tools
also help people get credit for their
work when they have like bit parts and
different forms of media so overall at
the end of this Arc it feels to me like
the creative sector actually does kind
of better than a lot of other parts of
the labor market in your world I'm
curious if this was meant as kind of
like a rebuttal to the current sense of
pessimism about ai's impacts on Creative
work I think for me yes I want to say
Yes
um I know that like Susan's work has
engaged with you know sort of questions
over the past year looking at this
program called creative informatics and
sort of investigating how data-driven
Innovation can broadly you know support
the creative Industries and support
creative practitioners and I think Tashi
also does that too with the music Realm
and I think me so my background is Art
and Design and I studied traditional
Arts of Japan and so I spent two years
in Japan working on no masks and
learning the art of no mask creation
um and I think what is no mask no is um
a Japanese theater that basically it's
if you've heard of Kabuki is similar to
Kabuki but with masks
um it is not for everyone uh I
particularly like the mass for sort of
their creepy elements it's kind of like
strong grimaces and they tend to be kind
of white painted is that imagine the
right thing okay exactly that's exactly
but I think part of that and part of I
think something we can learn from how
the Japanese preserve their arts and
cultures
um is something that I think really sort
of influenced thinking about the future
of art and craft I think even though a
lot of handicrafts seem to be dying off
and there seem to be being replaced by
sort of Automation and sort of mass
production there still really Is This
Love of keeping these crafts alive and
there is sort of this need for
governments to support handicrafts yeah
interesting so that that kind of
cultural value gives it more of a
lasting power than like you know manual
labor like there isn't so much of that
for like hand washing your dishes in
your clothes laughs
yeah interesting and and even to think
of like the Arts and Crafts movement
that occurred there has been over time
through Arts sort of this supporting and
need to build up and support the like
handmade and handcraft so there's always
this sort of dialogue and conversation
that goes on in art very cool
[Music]
process of World building has great
potential to make a positive future feel
more attainable this can be incredibly
powerful whether you're a creative
person looking to produce Rich works of
fiction or have a more technical focus
and are looking to reach policy makers
or the public
I asked Elaine and Vanessa what kind of
impact they hope their work would have
on the world
which aspects of your world would you
most like to see popular media take on
yeah I think well we were continuously
saying through throughout today was was
just kind of the
um the diversity part so just not
focusing on like the tech bro story or
like the what will the rich people do
once they can fly from one building to
the other in their like autonomous
drones but also thinking about the
stories that seem to be smaller but
actually maybe sometimes more common
um like the day-to-day and
and all the corners of the world yeah
the Indonesian Grandpa yeah yeah yeah
the older the younger people
[Music]
people well and I I think this is
something that Nicola pointed out is
that thinking about you know maybe the
more Cooperative opportunities that can
arise with new tech so instead of
thinking about technology as competition
and I think this is very relevant to how
we're looking at AI right now is like
this competition who's going to have the
strongest AI first because it's almost
become an arms race but thinking of well
how can we collaborate and sort of build
better technology through cooperation
yeah and I guess kind of seeing AI as
like
the side character of what we're
creating and as the character that is
interacting with humans yeah the
human-centered yeah I like that
what kinds of expertise would you be
most interested in having people bring
to these discussions
well none of us are economists so the
feasibility of of our world is something
we would definitely need some Economist
to sort of look at and be like
like I think I think especially with
like Ubi like Universal based income
that's definitely something that it's
like
well we read some articles and it looks
really good and people have said it's
good
um but also there's there's a lot of
political interdependencies and sort of
economic interdependencies that occur
that can be like I mean anytime we have
a depression in any Academy there
definitely is global impacts to that so
I think we we need more people thinking
about that aspect also of Technology
yeah and what about
um in discussions about like how to
develop AI systems what sorts of voices
or backgrounds would you want to to kind
of bolster in those areas
I guess basically the non-tech obsessed
people
um the the people who are used and
affected more than the people who just
want to create and want to sell it
yeah it's kind of a catch-22 it's like
that thing from Douglas Adams like the
only person who should be allowed to be
a leader is the one who doesn't want to
be you need people who don't really care
about AI development
and it is yeah it is difficult because
you I guess that's a difficulty in user
research as well that you're taking or
accessibility research probably that
you're taking the time from people who
have other things to do and other things
to worry about and so yeah it definitely
needs to be done in a way that benefits
them as well
yeah I mean that's that's tough I think
you're raising really interesting and
more fundamental problems that I'm
asking about I'm like which voices do
need to be like added into this and
you're kind of saying well there's a lot
of structural issues that make it hard
for those voices to get found and
included and like so maybe maybe the
feedback is more like we should be using
some of these
um like design research and audience
research approaches to actually like
find ways to co-develop the Technologies
that work for the people we're trying to
hear from yeah but also I think a point
that Vanessa is making is compensation
so I think we often go and I know
academics are guilty of this we often go
into these populations and are like tell
us about you tell us about what you want
and what you need and then we go and
here's a five pound voucher to some
random place that you've never been to
and it's like that's not helpful so I
think we need to get these voices heard
but we also need to recognize that there
is
this sort of equity that needs to be
created where it's like you know we're
compensating you for your time we're
compensating you for you know your
opinions like all of these sort of
things and not just monetarily like also
thinking about just other ways that we
can compensate yeah and some of the
Hidden costs probably of of sharing and
taking the time yeah what do you hope
that your world leaves people thinking
about like long after they've read it I
guess the hope is that people will think
more critically about everything about
the systems about the technology but
then also recognizing that you know
everyone needs to be a part of this and
so it's not just we don't want just the
people that are hyper Tech focused and
working on technology involved it's very
much like voting you think that like
you're one person your vote doesn't
matter but in actuality it's like no if
you and everyone else thinks like that
then it does affect things so
it's very much getting everyone involved
and making sure that everyone is
thinking about this
yeah and if they they read our thing and
they kind of didn't imagine to hear the
stories that we told about places that
we kind of focused on than maybe
question like so when you're thinking
about the future and what the future
looks like whose voice is narrating this
story who is telling this story and who
is included in that future and I can see
that even some people who are imagining
a futuristic scene wouldn't even think
about what their like own story in this
whole thing is but I think yeah that's
what we'd like people to think about
this has been a really great
conversation I really appreciate all the
perspectives and insights that you guys
have shared thanks so much for joining
us
yeah thank you for having us
thank you it was it was fun talking
[Music]
if this podcast has got you thinking
about the future you can find out more
about this world and explore the ideas
contained in the other worlds at
www.worldbuild.ai we want to hear your
thoughts are these worlds you'd want to
live in
if you've enjoyed this episode and would
like to help more people discover and
discuss these ideas you can give us a
rating or leave a comment wherever
you're listening to this podcast you
read all the comments and appreciate
every rating this podcast is produced
and edited by worldview studio and the
future of Life Institute fli is a
non-profit that works to reduce
large-scale risks from transformative
Technologies and promote the development
and use of these Technologies to benefit
all life on Earth we run educational
Outreach and grants programs and
advocate for better policy making in the
United Nations U.S government and
European Union institutions if you're a
Storyteller working on Films or other
creative projects about the future we
can also help you understand the science
and storytelling potential of
transformative Technologies
if you'd like to get in touch with us or
any of the teams featured on the podcast
to collaborate you can email World build
futureoflife.org
a reminder this podcast explores the
ideas created as part of fli's World
building contest and our hope is that
this series Sparks discussion about the
kinds of Futures we all want
the ideas we discuss here are not to be
taken as fli positions
you can find more about our work at
www.futureoflife.org or subscribe to our
newsletter to get updates on all our
projects
thanks for listening to imagine a world
stay tuned to explore more positive
futures
[Music]